did you know that the sun isn't really
on fire no our sun isn't a raging
bonfire in the center of the solar
system it's actually a nuclear reactor
you see inside Stars hydrogen atoms fuse
together to form helium atoms and during
that process of nuclear fusion enormous
amounts of energy are released that
energy shoots out in all directions
eventually making it way to you okay
let's keep the heat on and take a closer
look at some of the other seemingly
fiery objects in our night sky meteors
may look like they're on fire as they
Blaze their way through our atmosphere
but again that's not exactly the case if
you're lucky enough to catch a glimpse
of a shooting star what you're really
seeing is the glow from the intense air
pressure in front of the meteor as it
speeds through our atmosphere the rapid
compression of air in front of the
meteor Heats things up until it's
glowing bright and as a result of all
that heat meteors tend to burn up in our
atmosphere even though they aren't
technically on fire did you know that
2023 is going to be the hottest year on
record and the problem isn't just heat
waves and Wildfire soon you might not be
able to eat raw oysters warming waters
are helping bacteria to flourish making
raw oysters unsafe to eat
beer will taste worse and be more
expensive due to declining hops
production in Europe that's thanks to
the hotter Summers you know we're not
quite on track to where we want to be
when it comes to climate change but
progress is still possible the inflation
reduction Act is investing nearly
$370 billion towards climate and clean
energy initiatives and despite the
recent acceleration of global warming
remember humans are in the driver's seat
it's up to us to decide the future of
climate change now while our atmosphere
is our last line of defense
unfortunately some space rocks would
just be too big for the atmosphere to
consume before they crash into Earth so
just like in the movies if a giant
asteroid were headed our way we should
probably nuke it right uh-uh no way
while nuking it could help take a planet
killing asteroid down a couple notches
it wouldn't mean we'd be totally safe if
we nuked an asteroid it would break into
many smaller pieces and any one or
hundreds of those could still pose a
major Hazard to life on
Earth okay hopefully talking about the
terror of asteroids didn't scare you too
much if so wipe those tears from your
eyes did you know that you can't cry in
space well sort of you can cry as much
as you feel like but your teardrops
won't fall down your cheeks like they do
here on Earth thanks to the microgravity
in space if you stubbed your toe on the
International Space Station and started
to ball your eyes out your tears would
gather into a watery blob that would
float or stick to the front of your
face hey when you heard the word
microgravity just now you might have
done a double take weren't we always
told that there's no gravity in space
and if there's no gravity well there
must be no weight otherwise how could
astronauts just float around the
ISS well the term zero gravity is
misleading there will always be some
amount of force acting on an object in
the case of the astronauts on the ISS
they aren't actually weightless they're
in a constant state of Freefall thanks
to their orbit around the Earth they're
always falling but never
Landing in space no one can hear you
scream you might remember that as the
tagline to the movie Alien but it's only
true to a point while you'd never be
able to hear spaceships exploding like
you do in the movie there are some areas
in space where there may be enough
particles to allow sound to travel like
the hot gas clouds that surround some
black holes if there was enough gas you
might even catch a faint Whisper of what
a black hole sounds like speaking of
sound you may have heard that the planet
all have their own
song this one has roots going back
thousands of years when ancient
astronomers theorized about the Music of
the
Spheres they thought that the movements
of the planets might produce a form of
Music in itself well that didn't exactly
prove true but the magnetic fields of
the planets do interact with charged
particles and radio emissions that
results from that interaction can be
turned into sound waves don't worry
scientists have already done that for
you but these Eerie sounds aren't
exactly music to my
ears okay if we're still making noise it
would be a good time to talk about why
there's mostly no sound in
space that's because space is a vacuum
but not completely a vacuum occurs when
matter is absent no atoms no molecules
no nothing well sure space is pretty
empty but it's not a perfect vacuum
there will always be a few stray atoms
lurking in the gigantic voids between
galaxies okay maybe having less than one
atom for every cubic meter is really
really close to a vacuum but still it's
a
lie thanks to movies and pop culture
another lie you've been fed is what
happens when an astronaut is directly
exposed to space without a space suit if
you're out on a spacewalk and your suit
or your helmet are breached this would
definitely be bad news space is harsh to
the human body and unless you could
respond to the situation with lightning
speed you'd probably die but rest
assured you wouldn't spontaneously
explode while you're floating around out
there we might as well tackle another
misconception but for this we need to
change direction maybe try blowing air
in one direction to see if that'll move
you nope
and believe me it's not just because
you've got that helmet on your head even
if you could exhale forcefully it
wouldn't be strong enough to budge you
and that's why staying attached to the
handrails or having thrusters on your
suit is important to keep you close to
where you want to
be despite the legendary album by the
rock band Pink Floyd there isn't
actually a dark side of the moon at
least not one that's permanently dark
the reality is is that the Moon is is
tidily locked to the Earth that means
the moon takes the same amount of time
to make one full spin on its axis as it
does to revolve around the earth that
means you only ever get to see sunlight
hit one side of it but every Side of the
Moon gets lit every
day all right to wrap up this list of
Lies let's bring you all the way back
home to planet Earth now from your
Vantage Point out in space this
beautiful blue ball might have looked to
be a perfect sphere after all that's
what you've been told your whole life
but I bet you can guess what I'm going
to say next yeah that's another lie
Earth is technically an oblate spheroid
that means it's slightly flattened on
the North and South Poles while it
bulges out at the equator how did it get
this way well imagine that when the
planet was forming it was a bit like a
ball of clay as it spins the top and
bottom get a bit squished down while the
middle looks more
bloated okay that's enough space myths
to debunk in one sitting did it make you
wonder what other lies you've been told
how about some lies about the
dinosaurs well that's a story for
another what
[Music]
if